another very public reappearance of the
tennis star who vanished after she
accused a senior communist party
official of sexual assault
this time at an event to promote the
beijing winter olympics and miss pong
addressed those allegations for the
first time speaking to a reporter from
singaporean newspaper liane herzel who
happened to bump into her
firstly i want to emphasize that it's
very important i never said nor wrote
that i was sexually assaulted
i must emphasize that point clearly
then about weibo it's my privacy
maybe people have some misunderstanding
this was the post that pong made on
weibo a social media site in november in
it she does not use the chinese term for
sexual assault but she does say that jan
gao lee a very high ranking official
forced her into sex the post was removed
from the internet in just 20 minutes and
nothing was heard from pong for weeks
but then chinese state media posted
videos of miss pang in beijing along
with an email they said she'd written to
the head of the women's tennis
association to many it looks stage
managed and it did not convince the wta
which has suspended tournaments in china
as a result in a statement on monday the
organization said it still had
significant concerns about her
well-being and ability to communicate
without censorship or coercion
we remain steadfast in our call for a
full fair and transparent investigation
without censorship into her allegation
of sexual assault
ever since she reappeared we've only
seen pung through other people's videos
her weibo account where she spoke in her
own voice with great feeling and
intensity remains censored tom cheshire
sky news beijing